[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in mike florio the uh pro
football talk live co-host of course
football night in america is he 31
paulie yeah 31 oh okay
uh let's bring in florio why do you
think sean payton's in love with this
experiment with taysom hill i mean this
is a guy that taysom hill this is a guy
that sean payton discovered developed
groomed
and
you know it's getting to the point where
they've got to pick a lane for this guy
he's either going to be a quarterback or
he's going to be a jack of all trades
and i think the fact that he's so good
at other positions has
limited his growth as a quarterback he
hasn't gotten the opportunities you know
he didn't win the starting job this year
over jameis winston i think that was
very telling and now he's got this
convoluted contract that pays him a lot
of money if he plays quarterback and
plays well but based on what we saw last
night you're going to have the people
who say there's this segment of the fan
base out there generally that hates
taysom hill that thinks it's all a bunch
of hype that there isn't anything there
well he did go three in one last year
yeah when drew brees was injured they
forget about that and he did have a
jacked up finger last night and he
played with that and he didn't have
alvin kamara and they haven't had
michael thomas they got a bunch of guys
that we haven't really heard of before
running the routes and catching the
passes so is he ever going to be a
franchise quarterback no the question is
is it going to be good enough for sean
payton and my guess is when the dust
settles on this season peyton's gonna
see what's out there by way of
potentially finding himself
an upgrade that will
put them at a level that they were at
when they had drew brees for all this
but they're investing all this money in
him mike i don't understand that they
keep investing in him they're going to
have more money invested in taysom hill
than alvin kamara
well what they've got is 20 million over
the next two years 2022 and 2023 that's
the baseline that's as a practical
matter guaranteed to take some hill the
question is how much more above that
will he earn and he only earns more over
the next two seasons 22 and 23 by
playing quarterback having a minimum of
224 pass attempts each year playing well
at quarterback it's a very
carefully crafted
schedule and formula of how much more
he's going to make and he's got to do
this to make more if they make the
playoffs he gets more and if he plays
this much he gets more so
it was done to to basically pay as he
plays and pay as he plays well but it
gives the saints the flexibility to say
nah you know what we're gonna do we're
just gonna let you be full back hvac
tight end whatever
and you're going to throw a pass every
once in a while but you're not going to
be the regular quarterback they get to
make that decision they have the
exclusive right sean payton does to make
that decision what he's going to do with
taysom hill going forward yeah i just
think commit to him just see what he can
do if you think he's lamar jackson light
then let's just see it uh but i think
when you keep putting him in and then
you take him out and then you sort of
put him in and then you sort of take him
out i just i don't think you can and
quarterbacking is about rhythm it's
familiarity
being comfortable
explain the antonio brown situation
well you know the report first emerged
15 days ago that antonio brown used a
fake vaccination card and that
information came from his former live-in
chef
who allegedly had a bill that antonio
brown doesn't pay not the first time
that antonio brown has not paid his
bills and if he had only paid this guy's
bill we would have never known but
antonio brown had a fake vaccination
card it's so strange how things come to
life but the league investigated and
determined that three buccaneers players
antonio brown safety mike edwards and
john franklin iii who's no longer with
the team
misrepresented their vaccination status
and each is suspended three games for
franklin it doesn't matter he's not in
the league but the other two will lose
three game checks because of this and
it's all because of that fake
vaccination card and the temptation was
real and there had been chatter about
possible fake vaccination cards
throughout the season defector.com had a
great item about it back in september
i've heard espn has been sniffing around
it and doing some reporting on it and
planning something at some point on the
issue of fake vaccination cards but when
you look at the dramatic difference
between how vaccinated players are
treated and unvaccinated players are
treated
hey
you know there's a temptation to get a
fake vaccine card so you can choose to
not be vaccinated but take advantage of
the benefits of being vaccinated and
that's what antonio brown and others
have done how's this different from
aaron rodgers
well it's different because
antonio brown lied
to his team and to the league
aaron rodgers just lied to everybody
else
the the packers and the league knew that
aaron rodgers wasn't vaccinated but he
conducted himself in the public eye as
if he were vaccinated and the team in
the league let him do it showing up for
the press conferences twice a week in
the room in the facility with reporters
present no mask on that confirms what
aaron rodgers said on august 26 when he
was asked point blank are you vaccinated
and he said yeah i've been immunized
everything he did after that publicly
supported the idea that he was indeed
vaccinated so he lied to everybody else
brown lied to the league and that's why
brown got suspended now for some people
that's not good enough because they look
at and they say eliza lie i mean you're
endangering reporters by being in the
room by violating protocol and all he
ever was fined was fourteen thousand
dollars for going to that halloween
party there is a disparity there but the
big difference is
brown got a fake vaccination card used a
fake vaccination card aaron rodgers
didn't do that yeah i just wonder if
looking back the nfl and or the packers
should have just suspended aaron rodgers
the nfl should have suspended aaron
rodgers for a game just i mean they've
taken measures against teams
and
this is the quarterback of that team and
and i'm not
you know going after rogers in uh
specifically but he is the person that
we're talking about right now but there
have been other situations with the
raiders and the saints the titans other
teams
this is a team issue as well because the
team was aware of this and the nfl was
aware of this and it looks like the nfl
is complicit in this
oh absolutely dan because it's one thing
for the nfl to study surveillance
cameras to see whether or not aaron
rodgers is wearing his mask
in the building in the locker room etc
but everybody had access to the video
from the press conferences where he was
showing up without a mask on so the
league knew that he was violating
protocol the league knew the packers
were letting him violate protocol and as
i said at the time 300 000 fine to the
packers that's money well spent because
they didn't have to further undermine
their tenuous relationship with aaron
rodgers and because the packers
are publicly owned and they're currently
selling up to 300 000 shares of stock
for anybody who wants to hang a piece of
paper on their wall that is essentially
worthless other than the value of the
piece of paper
the money just comes off the balance
sheet it's not coming out anybody's
pocket mark murphy didn't get fined
three hundred thousand dollars he just
moved money around on the books and it's
money again it's money well spent
because they didn't risk further pissing
off a quarterback who was already upset
with them so the league should have
stepped in and said hey aaron you got to
wear your mask in these press
conferences or you have to do them by
zoom like you're doing them now
are the broncos being
well
sold
think eventually they will be look
they've got a strange situation there
it's been lingering for years pat bolan
the
late owner of the team put the team into
trust and created kind of this strange
intra family willy wonka competition
where the trustees would decide which of
his seven kids is suited to run the team
the problem is they all have to be on
board with it and if they're not on
board with it they've got to be bought
out or the team has to be sold and it's
been pointing in the direction number
one of this coming to a resolution next
year because the league is saying it's
time to resolve this and number two the
likely resolution being the highest
bidder buys the broncos
good stuff as always mike uh have a
great weekend thanks for joining us all
right dan good talking to you pal that's
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host and a contributor to football
night in america